a woman a tire that's fled a disease a
desire fears in front of you
fears that hold so still you can study
them like pieces on a chessboard it's
not the large things that send a man to
a madhouse death he's ready for or
murder incest robbery fire flood no it's
a continuing series of small tragedies
that send a man to the madhouse not the
death of his love but a shoelace that
snaps with no time left the dread of
life does that swarm of trivialities
that can kill quicker than cancer and
Witcher all was there license plates her
taxes or expired driver's license or
hiring or firing doing it or having it
done to you or constipation speeding
tickets rickets or crickets or mice or
termites or roaches or flies or a broken
hook on the screen or out of gas or too
much gas the sink stopped up the
landlord's drunk the president doesn't
care and the governor's crazy or making
it as a waitress at Norm's on the split
shift or as an emptier of bedpans or is
a car wash or a busboy or a stealer of
old ladies purses leaving them screaming
on the sidewalks with broken arm at the
age of 80 suddenly two red lights in
your rear-view mirror in blood in your
underwear
and there's always crabs and ingrown
toenails and people who insist they're
your friends there's always that and
worse leaky faucet Christ and Christmas
blue salami nine-day rains $0.50
avocados and purple livers with each
broken shoelace out of 100 broken
shoelaces one man one woman one thing
enters a madhouse so be careful when you
bend over
you